how are you Kevin I'm good how are you
I'm feeling sorry that once again we
brought you in here to play game you
probably would prefer not to play it's
fine you actually like undersold the
game a little bit we were like that's so
bad it's not worth mentioning it's not
like I love you on the ground is it is
that is that what if one gets on
GameSpot cuz it's got a four is one
pilot scale on the tray and you don't
want a scale of ten it's not like it's
just you know I don't know whatever or
band of flame yeah I know okay don't run
bound by flame okay yeah should I play
this I think we should jump right on it
in give the people what they want what
they want is bound by flame what's so I
got it can I do a little can I do a
quick blunder to address the alarming
fact that you are on fire I'm gonna do
this now this is a little a little
spoilery so the game so this is um I
think towards the end of the second
chapter
okay so Oh Bruce Willis it goes yeah I'm
at the stage where I see it over time
you make these decisions you have a
demon living in you over time you don't
we all sit ins on whether to on whether
to side with the demons advice or kind
of do your own okay and if you do more
demonic stuff than you start turning
into yeah guess which side Kevin Church
of the demonic eyes are glowing red
there's horns coming out it's Eddie's on
fire eventually you don't just have like
one set of horns to you get like
multiple sets of horns the more evil you
get I also read a new review that you
can't wear helmets because you can't you
can't I was kind of cool I'll show you
you absolutely you absolutely cannot
wear helmets books while we're here and
it's like no saying it doesn't say now
because I sleep I basically scrapped my
no hover for items but while we're doing
this if anyone has any questions as same
as ever in the twitch chat or in the
comments and add they'll be sent on over
to us questions are all gonna be why do
you suck this game is better than that
okay but so it's not a question I'm not
a big fan that's one of my favorite
things is when I
see transitions and everybody's in the
different position and they were in
because it's pre-rendered I love my
slave wow what is that ladies what this
is a Content ID okay yeah no that was
personal
yes monoxide he's Edwin she's just my
magician French who's whose breasts are
barely contained yeah actually just
resting on which he looks proper for
some people that's the proper place for
breasts to be barely contained I feel
like nothing she didn't dress for the
weather yes
if you know know also maybe she's cool
that's this guy he's got a frigging fur
coat on this concubine has given us an
opportunity we must attack her while her
troops so edwin's come on I'm gonna skip
ahead a little bit that was the story on
all the carcasses okay alright oh it's
no mass effect or anything so
mechanically I'm this is looking to me
like it could go either way between Dark
Souls or Viking battle of asthma they
try to do Dark Souls II more Witcher
okay but they don't quite get there for
quite a few reasons but so this is one
of the choices that you get to make I'm
going to I'm going to follow Edwin's
advice and say hey I need the I need the
power of the of the tree or okay I'm
going to try to save the the men and
this is kind of awkward they've been
staring at each other for a while now
well she just accused him of spying on
her while she bathes yeah yeah he's
totally a people tom peep what do they
call that peeping tom peeping tom time
goes by sharing and this woman's
presence you are legally classified as a
peeping tom ain't nowhere else repeat
I'm skipping ahead a little bit more no
down comes the concubine alright got
human legs and weirdos like spider legs
I said that theme with the cuddle thing
here I'm not sure how her arms even get
the theme exposed bosoms yes
ding-ding-ding all the dudes bosom seem
to be pretty wrapped up well now Kevin's
on fire bosom is a
all right Kevin else watching you fight
this concubine earlier a little bit and
what I really like about this character
model is like sick human legs just
dangling uselessly in front while she
struts around on these arachnid things
they're yeah they're growing yeah she
does hey Harris Pig how was the combat
not I'm doing a terrible jumble of right
posting is she going to stand up against
not wall the entire fight you rolled off
oh no see I could
I can't dodge in this particular stance
there there are three stances one is
warrior stance which is what I'm in now
I would show you the others but - there
we go - you got to double kicked so then
in these games really that combat is
gonna what makes it right so what's the
fundamental problem well part of it part
of it is everything - interrupts a
knock-back and and it's one of my little
pet peeves anyway when everything is
sort of an interrupted enough whoops I
hit the wrong button your guns crowd out
with stuff no not yet
swords on fire maybe you should hit her
with it that's what I'm gonna do first
I'm gonna heal up I don't want to die on
stream because that's never fun those
legs you know they remind me of I mean
you're our fighter labium earlier was
actually the the like Striders and
half-life 2 episode well yeah yeah
totally goes like tripod creaks oh I can
also change the perhaps yes small one
sorry I meant a smaller ones are the
human ones right of course yes I meant
the smaller and then walk over the trap
come on here Lee you're ignoring the
trap come on over the trap over the top
just bit would you walk on the tron come
on come on come on girlies come on ask
later okay there we go concubine yeah
there we go
mom girl over the trap over the trap
you've seen du spending a lot of time
and running around the circles to make
your house a fire go back up well that
happens a little bit but actually right
now I'm just trying to get her to come
over the trap you want to bait her onto
that your little yeah she's not really
into mind that you heard weather there
let's see come on over the traps I won't
be doing this because I want people to
see the traps is it that clear we know
they're not it's just a tiny that knows
it great great thank you oh that was
cool that was cooler than you're trapped
in the out class today yeah we did you
know what those weird legs remind me of
is those inflatable costumes that people
have that make them look like a centaur
or something we're like the bottom half
of their waist is dressed up as horse
legs and they just have these human legs
sticking out their front yeah yeah I
like it maybe we could dress up with
concubines next Halloween
last year probably be a little chilly
all right again does it take this long
to kill one enemy usually do you tend to
she's a she's a she's a boss okay how
bigger the mobs usually small it depends
like actually taking on one thing really
isn't that tough in this game but with
sometimes when you have multiple things
all at one time and they're all knocking
you around to interrupting everything
you do gets hard it's hard to get a
rhythm going so I just see Johnny fur
coat over here shooting arrows what
happened to Edwin of the Shelvin breath
he uh she's uh she's uh often was taken
it to go she's all physique you revived
I know can you only have one companion
at a time typically there are a couple
story points where are they using this
useless he's just standing in the
background yes there are always useful
okay take it some potshots except when
it's like a spellcaster sometimes they
can like you loose them in place or keep
them from casting spells which is nice I
think the problem is Edwin who is one of
the baby back and do that
Edwin the spellcaster who can do that
she's typically down in like fifteen
seconds oh my she'll come in and about
multiple enemies at one time she's down
and you can't revive her through
mechanics in the game you can revive her
by running away and tricking the game
into so that you pull enemies and leave
like the zone yeah like and then she'll
just stand up wherever she is and then
they just start in again right so there
are ways to get around it basically by
running away from battle but there's no
actual
right and nice guy 7-6 67 is a nice guy
and asks if you had to pick one nice
thing to say about this game what would
it be I actually really liked the
demonic stuff like I liked making the
decisions and then and then seeing how
that plays out physically it's sort of
like if fable football like like I don't
know a fable and Dragon Age kind of had
a baby on that right and then the baby
never really lived up to what its
parents were baby had like a really sad
I mean decent life
yeah and ever reach the place anyone
yeah yeah kind of a city wish you know
would have been a totally happy life if
not for the overachieving parents yeah
just like overshadowed that if babies
poured entire life pretty grim scenario
Evan what's this ad on this is on let me
see this is this is the PC version I'm
playing sure it is but this is also out
on PlayStation 4 and I believe
PlayStation 3
this more like a regular regular dude no
this is actually some big what you think
of is the big meanie in this game oops
oh this is a good time to show you some
crafting so you can craft anywhere which
is kind of making a solid hold up hold
up so I'm gonna make this hammer
Tio's so you can go in and choose health
potion and right now I can only may go -
all right however tainted blood you can
also go in there and see what else that
you're missing so I need tainted blood
to make potions now I can go ups wrong
button so now I can come over here and I
can make tainted blood from gold
what's oil if I wanted to I could make
53 tainted that is a lot of tainted a
message into blood and then I can go
back in to health potion is that like a
commentary on capitalism and then I can
make six more because I turned all my
gold Gold's like can be you know I'll
chemically change into anything in this
gift video games which is what I was
doing the goal of all alchemy is to
synthesize gold out of anything else
this is just the reversible it really is
Kevin thank you so much for bringing bad
boyfriend oh we done we are done with
how I played amazing